all right we've got a lot of heat that
we've got to face here this week
the rest of the week we've got 80s in
the valley outside the valley some
cooler 70s
indian springs para mesquite but just
about everybody else in southern
clark county is in the 80s right now
sandy valley 70s
90s at death valley boy caliente is
loving those upper 50s right now
we're looking at 114 we were 110
yesterday going up another four degrees
well above the 99 average and 115 is the
record
so close to that they've had a lot of
powerful storms across the now
northeast a lot of high winds and downed
trees middle of the country is fairly
quiet for now
and we've got all of this heat across
the west they're about 50 million
people in the sights and sitting under
these excessive heat warnings across
about five to six states
from colorado california and of course
we're right in the middle of that
excessive heat warning still in place
for us
all the way through saturday night also
heat advisories now for the mountains
those take effect 10 a.m this morning
all the way through saturday evening
all thanks to this ridge of high
pressure now bianca and i were talking
earlier about possible lightning strikes
which would cause
could cause wildfires it's all from
moisture being pulled up from mexico
there was convection last night and
we've seen a little this morning over
mexico and baja
by at least thursday we're thinking we
could see some dry lightning up in our
mountains
and that's been known to cause wildfires
a big concern this time of year
today upper 80s warm and breezy red rock
up to 109
today while the valley cooks at 114 even
hotter tomorrow at 1
16. and then you can see 114 thursday
through saturday
relentless heat long long duration heat
wave and that's what's so dangerous
about it
into dad's day is still 110 please be
safe
we could take a day or two but when
you've got five six seven days of
it it gets tense